si vous étiez un microbe
un microbe de 1 m 80
bien on va faire un petit portrait
chinois vous êtes prêts
chinois attention
[Musique]
si vous étiez un défaut Marina vous
seriez quoi
la radinerie
et toi
va te faire cuire le cul
si vous êtes une maladie
je serai un toc trouve l'obsession
qui sera produite bientôt l'année
prochaine et alors donne-nous la
meilleure vanne pour voir ça commence le
mec il dit première réplique c'est
d'aller tous vous faire [ __ ] c'est
bien je t'adonne
si vous étiez une maladie
ou un petit rhume mais avec plein de
morve voilà c'est exactement ce que
j'allais dire si vous étiez un accident
incroyable
alors moi je serai un accident très
idiot qui est arrivé pour de vrai à la
mer d'un ami elle s'est auto écrasée
avec sa voiture
c'est à dire qu'elle était dans un
parking de son parking là qui était en
pente et elle a oublié le frein à main
elle est sortie pour prendre un truc et
paf le pied c'est coincé et attendez
c'était très grave parce qu'on a du
Lyautey les deux poumons tous les
poumons tout
si vous étiez une perversion Marina
une perversion la vieilleophilie
si vous étiez une perversion je serai
ce que vous m'avez proposé de faire en
coulisse tout à fait
si vous étiez un indice une boule
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
aller chez Fogiel
une trahison je balancerai ce que vous
m'avez proposé de faire un coulisse
si vous étiez un poison
à la cigarette j'aime trop c'est bien
bien
[Rires]
si vous étiez une femme
oh ça va on a le droit d'être très
grossi au moins une fois par semaine
d'électricité pendant la finale de la
Coupe du monde
si vous étiez une infirmité
S
quelqu'un qui fera un crime parfait
d'ailleurs je sais ce que c'est que le
crime parfait j'y réfléchi c'est un
crime gratuit parce que si c'est un acte
gratuit c'est impossible qu'on retrouve
alors ce soir Marina a donné des bons
conseils fumer un crime gratuit parfait
si vous étiez une mort
pas définitive
si vous étiez un microbe
un microbe de 1 m 80
[Rires]
allez s'il te plaît
[Applaudissements]
oh merci Serge même si tu trouves que je
suis mal habillé merci quoi il a dit que
c'était même habillé
ne sait pas que Serge caleçon s'habille
exclusivement en Prada donc forcément
quand tu vois un t-shirt il a des
boutons
réalisateur mannequin
t'entends pas il n'est pas des
changements
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu